[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui on est sur la plage de
comment s'appelle yum kidung et on va
faire une épreuve des bouées
[Musique]
sur la cette scène là ça fait deux
semaines que j'y pense au final ça va et
c'est beau on est bien cet aprèm ce sera
peut-être un peu plus compliqué mais
pour l'instant
j'ai pissé dans l'eau je me suis
réchauffé
vachement parce que je suis très frileux
trop bien au final c'est mon jour limite
préféré
tout le temps mais ça ne voulait pas
dire qu'il faisait pour autant très très
chaud
[Musique]
on a tourné en octobre novembre et la
mer était plus si chaude que ça et à 7h
du matin tout d'un coup elle paraissait
très fraîche mais en vérité l'eau était
pas si froide que ça
moi j'étais devant je dirais je vous ai
entendu tous gueuler un peu ah les froid
de froide ça allait ça va franchement je
m'attendais pas à ça aller à 20 21
degrés quoi
c'est l'épreuve de l'épisode 2 une
épreuve un peu particulière j'ose pas
trop en parler parce qu'à chaque fois
j'ai honte mais les gens ont la tourista
ils doivent pousser
[Applaudissements]
et puis oui
on apprend que il y a des requins
étonnamment en Méditerranée on apprend
que les requins adorent la merde ce qui
est une théorie que je crois à 1000%
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
c'était franchement c'était physique
pendant les prisons on commence le truc
et on se rend compte que waouh mais j'ai
l'impression d'être en slow motion
tellement tellement c'est dur en fait on
marchait dans l'eau au fur et à mesure
en fait nous elle sur le haut de la tête
et quoi donc littéralement se noyer mais
on disait rien parce qu'on disait que
c'était l'épreuve et que c'était comme
ça
en fait
[Musique]
on voulait aller au bout aussi de ce
truc qui tu vois de la garde de sa fille
de se dire waouh là il y a son ex-femme
à cette caméra là il y a deux caméras
ici qui sont là donc pour tous les
retournements avec eux il y a une autre
caméra
[Applaudissements]
mon principal problème dans cette dans
cette aventure comme ils disent c'est
mon ex-femme c'est Carole parce qu'elle
est méchante et qu'on se déchire la
garde de notre fille je sors pas
si elle sort pas parce que je sors pas
je continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup de vagues du courant et qu'à la
fin je suis la dernière avec Ramzi à
voilà et en bas on se balle contre
l'autre mais moi j'ai vraiment moi
Natacha je me suis dit je vais crever en
fait je vais jamais arriver à tirer le
truc je vais me prendre les vagues à
accrocher donc je suis pas du tout en
train de jouer la comédie je je suis
désespérée et en train de pousser des
cris vrai
et c'était quand même fou on faisait une
vraie épreuve en fait sans le danger
parce qu'il y a l'équipe et tout ça mais
c'était drôle à faire
j'ai rien appris parce que Carole elle
voit le requin elle veut voir le requin
bouffer le son mari n'a rien à [ __ ]
elle veut gagner c'est pour te dire
on apprend que ça fait pas si mal de se
faire bouffer la jambe
et on apprend qu'on peut retrouver le
requin à l'autre bout du monde et
récupérer
[Applaudissements]
s où on joue pas on est vraiment surpris
par le courant l'eau cette bouée qui
pèse très très lourd donc en fait on n'a
pas besoin de jouer on vit le truc et
c'est et c'est pour ça que j'entends
était très très heureux quand il me
voyait parce qu'il disait ça marche ça
marche super parce qu'effectivement on
nous voyait l'eau qui montait les trucs
évidemment qu'on ne peut pas répéter
quand il y a une vague qui vous arrive
en pleine gueule c'était pareil sur les
radeaux et un moment je suis tombé donc
c'est
là pour le coup ça devient vraiment de
la real TV
ah c'est parti
justement ce qui a été exceptionnel dans
dans le tournage c'est qu'il y a eu
vraiment une vraie bascule sur une
épreuve d'eau qui est l'épreuve des
radeaux
où on avait peur de cette épreuve parce
que tout le monde t'a 16 personnes qui
doivent être dans l'eau en train de
pailler enfin je veux dire à subir l'eau
froide tout le monde avait mis combi
enfin tout le monde avait peur tu vois
et puis c'est passé un truc de fou je
sais pas c'est que je crois que tout le
monde s'est rendu compte en même temps
qu'on vivait un truc exceptionnel c'est
à dire que personne n'a jamais fait ça
de sa vie personne ne sait jamais trouvé
sur des radeaux à pagayer et on se dit
mais en fait c'est génial ce qu'on est
en train de faire c'est génial ce qu'on
est en train de vivre et on y est est
allé tu vois et au final la grénaline
elle se fait que tu penses même pas au
fait que tu sois dans l'eau tu t'amuses
juste et au final tu même tu joues mieux
parce que tu dis allez je vais pas faire
1000 prises là je suis dans l'eau il
fait froid on y va à fond et là en fait
c'est une sorte de lâcher prise de tout
le monde parce que il y a tellement eu
des vagues que déjà on n'a pas besoin de
jouer nous en tant que comédien à ce
moment-là le fait excité sur un radeau
puisqu'on est très clairement excité par
la situation et ce qui était très
marrant c'est que parfois on faisait des
répliques mais on voyait que la vague
allait passer entre nous les techniciens
donc en fait ça servait à rien de faire
notre épique parce qu'on faisait un
vague il avait pas encore et hop elle
fasse la réplique parce qu'on sentait
qu'il l'avait pas eu on les voyait plus
en fait si tu veux donc on voyait qui
nous filmait plus c'était sportif mais
je dois admettre que au jour où on a
fait ces séquences de do pour nous tous
on avait un peu le sentiment de faire la
vraie émission et ça nous a tous
vachement galvanisé c'était pas facile
techniquement mais c'était assez
jouissif de le faire et on a eu le
sentiment que bah voilà en tout cas moi
j'ai envie de gagner ce jour-là
[Musique]